so are aliens flying around our world
or not american intelligence officials
say they have found
no evidence that aliens are responsible
for recent unidentified flying objects
ufos
spotted by military pilots and others
but those same intel officials also
quote cannot rule out the possibility of
extraterrestrial involvement
so what does that mean where does that
put us this all comes out ahead of a
major report to congress expected later
this month
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin has our story
a new highly anticipated report to
congress about ufos
says there is no conclusive explanation
for more than 120
incidents of navy pilots reporting
flying
objects that seem to blow past the
boundaries of cutting-edge aviation
technology
senator marco rubio was among those who
inserted language into president trump's
last spending bill mandating the report
to congress
there are things that are not ours
flying over military installations
talking about these things flying around
we just don't know what they are we need
to know what they are
the director of national intelligence
will release an unclassified report with
a classified annex to congress this
month
which concludes there's no evidence
these ufos are alien spaceships
nor is it some classified american
technology
some u.s officials believe the ufos are
potentially from russia or china
and have hypothesized it could mean
america's adversaries have outpaced the
united states
in the development of hypersonic weapons
or surveillance drones
other experts believe this could be
equipment malfunction from aging u.s
jets fitted with new radar systems that
have glitches
we take all incursions into
our operating spaces seriously at the
defense department
certainly we are taking the entire
matter
seriously even president obama has
weighed in i would hope
that the knowledge that there were
aliens out there would solidify people's
sense that
what we have in common is a little more
important but no doubt there would be
immediate arguments about well you know
we need to spend a lot more money on
weapon systems to defend ourselves
president obama says that there is
footage
and records of objects in the skies
and he says we don't know exactly what
they
are what do you think that it is i would
ask him again
thank you the report produced with the
pentagon is likely to disappoint ufo
enthusiasts
and those who want more answers i'm told
by those
who are familiar with the findings brett
we'll continue to ask the questions
jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thanks